joan rivers is a uh is
like she holds a special place in my
heart when i was at nbc
joan rivers was the host of the tonight
show with johnny carson and she would
come on my show
and that was a big deal back then
because most celebrities did not want to
come on my show i was
you know a bit of a pariah but joan
didn't care she thought i was funny
and she loved coming on and she didn't
care what i asked her
someone told me that frank sinatra who
could have banged any chick he wanted
try to bang you yeah did he say did he
come right out and say to you
joan i want to bang you the hand brushes
again on your ass
you know show me what he did uh
and she was the first one ever to invite
me to our home i was shocked
no celebrity had ever invited me to
their home and joan rivers was having a
party
first thing that struck me was i was
like wow there's no food here
joan would have a party and it was like
a tea party howard i served great food i
probably didn't go in the dining room i
was starving we went into the dinner i
went
we would believe me if there was food we
would have found it the guy walks
everybody hands you a
cream cheese sandwich exactly that was
what was in
the dining room he had a little shrimp i
couldn't see him they were like baby
shrimpy had a
toothpick i mean i never saw a party
like that no food
it's 6 30 at night and there's no food
sandwiches in the dining room she's a
jewish comedian but she lived like a
wasp
and the party's going on it's about 6 30
and figure well i think it was going to
be dinner we had buffet
you know you threw me out and had buffet
i had great buffets she goes well a
couple of people are staying for dinner
but uh unfortunately everyone else has
to leave she didn't tell us that we
found that out later
you people just don't understand every
appearance of hers was special
and funny and raw what do you think you
spend a year
a lot a couple million dollars huh yeah
a lot i have a lot of uh
yeah i spent a lot but you know when i
was like i believe i swear to god
have a good time everybody's taken care
of
everybody's fine and i'm having a good
time too buy that jacket
plant that tree that jacket you're
wearing today looks very expensive this
was given to me by a friend named margie
stern woman gave it a jewish woman gave
it to me relatives ask you for money all
the time all the time
all the time all the time what do you
say to them [ __ ] off
[Laughter]
one of the best talk show guests i miss
her
you